coup de jeune pour le poney club ucpa de
la ferme du manet de montigny le
bretonneux
installé depuis 1991 dans l'ancien
pavillon de chasse de la ferme du mané
le cloud va rentrer d'ici la fin du mois
de mars dans la dernière des trois
phases de réhabilitation de l'équipe non
la ville est propriétaire donc des
bâtiments et donc le poney poney club
boucle cpa et donc c'est une délégation
de service public et donc dans nos
engagements la ville s'était donc
engagée à agrandir ce poney club des
travaux permettront un agrandissement
duc la base de plus de 115 mètres carrés
avec un nouveau foyer de 60 m² une
remise aux normes de la partie existante
créée il ya 25 ans est également prévue
celle ci pour répondre aux critères
d'accessibilité dès personnes à mobilité
réduite avec création d'équipements
sanitaires adaptés à la partie extension
ce qui est intéressant c'est donc de
vous il va y aura foyer qui va faire
environ 60 mètres carrés où donc les
gens les enfants pourront dire
travailler enfin faire des activités et
où les parents pourront depuis la salle
avec une grande paroi vitrée voir depuis
sur le lapident carrière on peut voir
les enfants évoluer moi je vais être à
vie parce qu'on aura un accès pour les
handicapés pour les personnes à mobilité
réduite les parents et clients des
visiteurs il ya de plus en plus de monde
qui vient du coup c'est bien d'agrandir
aussi et vu qu'on a déjà fait d'autres
travaux c'est bien maintenant on peut
voir des manèges depuis l'intérieur on
n'est pas obligé l'hiver quand il pleut
de rester au bord du manège pour
regarder le nouveau bâtiment devrait
être livré d'ici l'automne prochain coût
de l'opération 6 135 mille euros